When something is stored in the cloud,...
...that means it's stored on internet servers instead of on your computer.
It's like having an extra hard drive,...
...one that you can access anywhere and anytime you're connected to the internet.
In the past, you only had a home computer and the software you installed on it.
Now you can take your files anywhere thanks to cloud-based applications called web apps,...
...which run inside your internet browser.
A web app that you may already use is Google Docs.
It's free.
You don't have to install anything to use it,...
...and it allows you to create several different types of projects.
You can access everything that you create in Google Docs...
...from any computer or device with an internet connection.
Since you only need a connected device  to access the cloud,...
...you can take your music, photos and videos with you wherever you go.